Mà Mà Y Bóc Ngài Hà Mà Chị tâm em một đã yêu cầu 3 chân năm 2018 trên tròn thế giới,
tạm dừng khai tháp lương sống như Mà Mà Hà Mà Hà Mà Hà Mà Y để các cuộc một lỗi phần mềm trong hệ thống đu khuyện bài.
Lên chưa hồi lập tất gây dạng đoạn tại nhiều sinh bài cho à và cho ốc trong khi Mỹ trình bị bước vào ra đoạn cao điểm hậu lệ tạo hơn.
Lối kiến thuật được phát hiện sau sự cố tốt lộ cao mạnh của một chuyển Ject Lu của thống người.
A Bóc Chò biết, bils phó có phục chủ yếu là được hệ thống về phía bản phẩm mềm cố,
mà không cần điều câu thay thế lịch kện nào.
Nếu hạ lương vào cao tính độ nhàng như WIS A, hoàn tất cả mẹ trong đêm A a giờ,
huy động được lượng tí thuật làm việc xây vòng.
A n度 cho biết toàn bộ phía độ A Bóc sẽ được cầm nhật sông trước ngày bảo mùi thầm em một tà Nhật Bản.
A a a hì hình hình gần một chăm chuyến trong khi các hạng ở hành Quốc và hông công chỉ có nhận chắc huy giải giá.
Tại vì A American Airlines sở lỗi cho hơn 2 trong trước, a bà hay mười,
đào tà như nơi tật và Ject Lu cũng chuyển khai quy trình tất tượng.
Dù chỉ cần tắt động phần mềm là mấy mây có thể vào động trở lại.
Nhưng quy mô chua hồi rất lớn, vô cá hẳng bài tư tiên các cuộc để hạng trẻ trạm trẻ cáo dài.